*Amazing Trumpet Intro*
Meme revieeeeeeeeeew!
*clap*
*clap
wooooooo
It's spooky time
spoopy time
It's October everybody
and you know what that means.
Every year on meme review.
It's spoopy time
the favorite time of year where we review
spoopy
memes
*clap* *clap*
Can we get some really creepy music
some really Shane Dawson (not copyrighted) montage documentary style
Mooousic
to really set the tone of this (spoopy) meme review.
*clap* *clap*
and let's review some freaking creep- spoopy
spoopy memes...
Our first
spoopy
meme.
♪Don't get too spooped out now♪
All right.
We got Mickey Mouse.
Hey, what is he doing?
Is he gonna take pizza?
That would be spoopy.
*gasp*
Ah!
Aah!
Aaah!
He stole the children!
He sto-
I am so spooped out
How am I going to trust Mickey Mouse from now on?
I thought he was one of the good guys. *same, now I can watch Mickey Mouse jumpscares and think 'BASED ON A TRUE STORY*
Mickey Mouse
Confirmed
sociopath.
Time for spoopy meme number two.
Everyone. We have an announcement to make
♪♫♬Stoooppp bullying♪♫♬
I just got the chills
We don't play around here on spoopy month on meme review.
Damn.
Yeah, I masturbate
Upvote, spooky memes.
Gucci gang
Have you guys thumbs up this video yet.
Make sure you do
otherwise,
I bet you have your flesh and skin exposed. What are you some kind of loser?
I bet you fapped to Bowsette in October inappropriate.
Eggcuse me Bowsette, you can look at the door, because I only want
Woody, I only want Voody's Vood. Bowsette you're ugly.
I don't care. When she sends nudes, but you wanted spooky memes.
When she sends nudes, but she doesn't send her skeleton.
I hate it.
Disgusting, does she not get it?
All right we have Peppa the pig, Peppa the pig. Oh, oh my GOD
Peppa the pig has four eyes if you think about it. Okay, that is actually genuinely
terrifying what in the actual *time to play fill in the blanks! poodiepie means... FRICK*
(reads meme)
I don't know
It's spoopy month mom, don't you get it?
White boi, Black boi, Asian boi, Gay boi, Straight boi,
Bois that think spooking isn't cool.
Huh? Have you thumbs up this video to prove that you think it's cool yet?
*assorted poodiepie noises* Damn *more spoopy noises*
*some weird noise that I can't figure out how to spell* *forgive me, I'm only a nine-year-old*
LÄMP! LÄMP!
Everybody. YouTube has just
YouTube, really the internet has been taken over by lämps and møths. It's a love story,
well-fitting of spoopy month.
*clap**clap*
Meme review everybody. Oh wait, I forgot new merch. Meme review official merch everybody
It doesn't get any better than this. Alright and well fitted for the spoopy month clap clap
Do you think you have what it takes? Meme review everybody?
We also have a hat that says Please be patient,  I'm 9 years old
So people will know. Now where was I? That's right, møth memes.
Hi Um, let me get a large LÄMP. Can someone please give møth a LÄMP? I think it's only fair.
It's a love story. It's a romance better than Twilight
*watches the møth go to the window*
Møth: Lämp I want you lamp
Lämp: Møth we cannot be together
Moth: This window is only a temporary obstacle Lämp
Lämp:  It's not that
Møth: Then what is it
Lämp: The power is going out,
(Pewdiepie mourns this tragic turn of events) Møth: No Lämp.
Lämp: I am dying Møth.
*This should be a fanfiction*                 Møth: No Lämp you can not leave me ;C.
Lämp: You have to let me go Møth.
Møth: Do not give up on me Lämp.
Lämp: You have to  le-  ;0 LÄMP !
LÄMP! (RIP LÄMP Died October 2, 2018)
I didn't think I would cry again on camera. Last time, it was Walking Dead.
Her: He's probably thinking about other girls. Him: lämp
Lämp. Are the Lämps ready brother? This meme started off from a reddit post which showed this
Horrific møth. I'm sorry to call him that. Close-up of møth outside my window Jesus Christ.
but it also shows an expression, a side of møth that we haven't seen before a
Humanizing of the møth. *oooh, we're poetic and artistic now* Usually I see a møth and I just want to kill it now
I see a møth and I go that's a sexy møth. Oh, I'm sorry
Are we are we going to pretend that we're not attracted to møth all of a sudden.
Have you seen this? Huh?
Don't tell me you wouldn't smash that. Not convinced are you?
How about this image getting turned on by this image: preteen boys on the Internet 2010, and møth
You're lying. you're lying to yourself. If you don't think møths are attractive. Don't look at me like that
You fapped to Bowsette, didn't you you weirdo you see you just add the math to the moth
It all make sense.
big titty møth girlfriend.
Tell me, tell me honestly
What do you think of this?
Lämps are effing sick.
Change my mind. You can't. You just can't.
Hey, look, it's this meme again making its 4000th, four hundred millionth appearance
Do you want anything from Ikea? Lämp. Just give me a lämp. That's all I want. I can't hold on
Give me your hand
First give me the lämp. That is so clever when you found out Paris is the city of lights
What is this 2012 2012 memes?
*laughter*
When you found out there are oil lämps. Hey, hey, hey, this is totally me guys. This is so relatable.
*clap**clap*
Meme review. Hey look that looks pretty cool
Buy the merch. Okay, guys Yaga mean light. Yeah
Get it cuz his name is light in there. It's probably too complex for you. The møth memes really are very
Complex. Møth: God I wish there were me poor moth. They just want lämp, and that's it. One day
I'm going to be a beautiful butterfly
several poor life decisions later
Lämp
The lämp everybody.
THANOS MØTH
That's incredible. I like how the møth
The møth means a sort of a weird Ugandan. Lämp and brother, brother as a certain way of articulating
Itself, it's a reminiscent to say the least, of better times. Hello, may I acquire the lämp?
*shaking lämp noises*
*noice lämp music*
Lämp time!
It's lämp time! (It's Ugandan Knuckles!)
Oh Yeah
I feel it
DID SOME LEPIDOPTERA JUST SAY LÄMP? oh, my gosh.
Like for free Honda EU2200i 2200-Watt120-Volt super quiet portable inverter generator
Well you heard the man, smash like
Good morning 'MØTHS'
Lets get this 'LÄMP' *laughs*
Good morning 'MØTHS' lets get this
'LÄMP'
You heard her everybody, smash like on the video and give me-- I mean buy the merch.
Enough of that
Go away damn you
Well, you're going to get it now
*Beats the sh*t out*
Lämp-lämp
Lämp brother so I've been trying to figure out this meme
but I don't get it like where's the punch line? *you can't talk, all of your punchlines are lämp*
2018 memes are just so confusing.
Lämp salesman: slaps top of lämp. Lämp salesman: slaps top of lämp again
Slaps top of lämp again. I like this one. It's clever.
It's very. Good touching lämp because lämp is good. Dying because lämp is hot.
Perfectly balanced as all things should be. The møth meme
(Clap clap)
Gets extra 5 points for being disgusting. extra 10 points for being spoopy in spoop-tober
mmm an extra
- five points for I don't know no reason and the result is
(Clap, clap)
7.5
Everybody. Wow, that's really good
Congratulations møth meme you scored very high on the meme review chart.
Hopefully you'll live a couple more days
The last meme of this week is the tik tok bad guys
Now I can't show the actual audio because they'll just claim all the revenue on the video
and if I can't make money off of memes
Then what's the point? Why would I even bother doing it?
So instead you'll get the copyright free PewDiePie singing version of this meme
Feel free to use this if you ever want to review it as well
Why do good girls only like bad guys had this question for a real long time right bad?
40s going to see. You know,
Musical.ly died, but it's just like any other cancer it comes back in a different form. We were so happy
We were celebrating musical.ly is gone
dododododododododo
but no it came back and it came back stronger than ever with tik tok
so now not just kids are posting, actual adults are posting these memes where they
Transform from this really good guy to this really cool bad guy with this cringy
Song in the background. I don't know what it is, but it goes like 'why do good girls only like bad guys...
...I had this question for a long time little bad for yet plain to see'
The wider world where love with me
What in the actual... The thing is like there's so many cringy ones that I can't tell which ones are joking or not
(De la musique)
Goddamn ads!!!!!
This meme gets
(The Clap that kills the memes)
-10 points for having
Copyrighted. Okay, stop using music in your memes, please. I guess another - I don't know
I don't like it. It gets a zero. Okay zero. That's right.
Oh!
That's enough
That's all the time we have for this week's meme review everybody!
YouTube's  favorite Show
check out the merch link in the description
Thank you guys so much for supporting this show. I really appreciate it and I see you guys next time
Epic BroFist!
EPIC brofist